[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
It was 1995 when
the call came from the
genetic counselor telling me
that our daughter, Mallory,
had cystic fibrosis.
It would take a few
minutes before I
came to understand that the
wailing noises that I was
hearing were coming from me.
At the time, Mallory was three.
Soon after, we sat
with a CF specialist
who described what life
would be like for Mallory
moving forward--
the machines she would need,
the medicines she would take,
the limitations she would face.
He calmly told us that the
lifespan for kids with CF
had changed from five to 25,
and he expected that trajectory
to get even longer.
With that one sentence, he
introduced our new normal--
a childhood with
an expiration date.
As I sat there bawling my
eyes out, I turned to him
and asked, how do you deal with
hysterical parents and very,
very sick children?
His answer provided a lot
of perspective for me.
He said that during
his career he
often treated kids who had been
beaten, burned, or abandoned,
and that he looked
around the room
and saw Mallory filled with
love and happiness, surrounded
by her parents and
her grandparents,
and he reassured me that
she would live a happy life.
Before Mallory's diagnosis,
she had a lot of symptoms--
a persistent cough,
a chronic runny nose,
a massive bowel movements,
the first indication
that gastrointestinal
problems would plague her
for the rest of her life.
Once Mallory started
the CF protocol,
it was hard to get
her to do treatments.
But the treatments
actually helped
and the symptoms were abated.
Specifically what she had to
do was inhale a bronchodilator,
use mucus thinners, and have
chest percussion therapy,
like this, to dislodge the
mucus from her chest wall.
Every night, when it
was time for treatment,
Mallory would hide.
She hated it.
In the closet, under
the bed, anywhere she
thought we wouldn't find her.
So Mark made up a game
called Astronaut and Pat Pat,
Astronaut for the machine
and the swirling medicines,
and Pat Pat for the
chest percussion therapy.
At the time, I was
desperate for a way
to explain the disease to
Mallory, to her brother, Micah,
and to all of our community.
There was no book for
kids with CF back then,
and I wanted everyone
to understand
why she had to do treatment,
why she had to take pills,
and wine she was often
absent from school.
It was terrifying
to me, so I assumed
it would be terrifying to her.
What I did was write
a children's book
called "Mallory's 65 Roses."
65 roses is what kids hear when
adults say cystic fibrosis.
We read it to her
class every September,
I gave it out to
all her friends,
and I sent it with her
when she went to camp.
And it worked.
Mallory led a pretty
normal childhood.
Through the years,
I would give it
to the boys she
would date because it
was a really simple
explanation for what it was
that Mallory had to deal with.
Mallory's classmates and
her friends read the book
and treated her,
throughout her childhood,
as if she were a regular kid.
And she got to play
sports, go to school,
and have a very happy childhood.
During the years,
Mallory's medical teams
became a huge part of our lives.
We were lucky to have the best
of the best at Cedars, UCLA,
Stanford, and UPMC.
The most perceptive
doctors recognized
Mallory's uncanny ability
to understand and articulate
what she was dealing with
and what she had to do.
And then what they did
was they used her insights
to provide her with better care.
Because she was so compliant,
so sweet, and so thoroughly
understanding, the
doctors often asked
if medical students
and residents
could come to her room
for bedside training.
Mallory always said yes.
She was always engaged.
They called her the poster
child for compliance,
and they always loved her.
They did not always love me.
I was the bad cop to
Mallory's good cop.
My job was to protect her even
when it made me unpopular.
I was known to do a number of
different things, one of them,
block the door to any person
trying to enter before 6 AM
that wasn't an urgent matter.
For example, somebody coming
to take out the trash,
or a nursing assistant
wanting to write daily goals
on the whiteboard, or
sometimes a phlebotomist
wanted to come draw
routine labs, that
had already been drawn
the night before, at 5 AM.
Sometimes it was
a medical student,
very eager to please
the attending,
and really just wanted to
interview Mallory, which
we always said yes
to after 10:00 AM
but I said no to at 5:00 AM.
It's different
when someone comes
into the hospital for
a one-off procedure
or they're sick with something
that's just a happenstance.
But when you have
a chronic illness
and you have repeated
hospitalizations,
sleep is a very critical
form of medicine,
and sometimes people
seem to forget.
I also would sneak Mallory
out of the hospital
for long walks, and one
time, arranged for somebody
to pick her up and take her
to a football game for three
hours between her treatments,
and then I sat by the door
and pretended that she was
taking a nap and blocking it.
You can imagine how they felt
about me when they found out.
I also insisted that
Mallory keep enzymes
by the bedside, which the
pharmacy wanted to control,
because it's a medicine she
takes every single day at home
on her own.
And if you don't have your
enzymes, you can't eat.
Friends would drop by with
ice cream that would melt.
A nurse might be in the next
room with a coding patient,
and it would not be appropriate
for me to be demanding
that she get her pills.
And yet I wanted to
make sure that she
was able to live a normal
life and be with her friends.
I pushed for faster
response times
when delays put me at risk.
Now through all this, I was
supported by my husband, Mark,
who was normally a very
kind and patient man.
His job was to fight
the insurance companies
to get approvals, to research
better treatment options,
and to sleep
bedside in a blow up
bed to make sure Mallory
was never alone at night.
Usually kind and
patient, as I mentioned,
Mark refused to tolerate errors
or mistakes, which sometimes
made him unpopular too.
Now all of this leads to the
first of Mallory's insights
I'm going to share today, and
there will be six in total.
Parents play an important
role in treating a child
with chronic illness.
Now, that seems like
an obvious, right?
Duh.
But what you'll find out, if you
haven't already experienced it,
is that sometimes,
when parents advocate
on behalf of their
child, it puts them
at odds with both the
system or with the doctors,
and it leads to conflict.
Anybody who lives in
this world will tell you
that the best
collaborations come
when doctors, parents, and
patients collaborate together.
When Mallory was 12,
life changed again.
We got the call saying
that her lungs had
been colonized by the
normally harmless bacteria
called B. cepacia.
When patients with CF get
cepacia, one of three things
happens.
The first is it turns into
a very serious illness
and the patient dies right away.
The second, there's a
peaceful coexistence
and somehow it doesn't seem
to bother the patient with CF.
In the third case, it can
be a long, slow progression
of disease that results
in death about 10 years
after the initial colonization.
We tried to explain to
Mallory and to Micah
that things would become
a lot more difficult.
This is Mallory's
brother, Micah,
who always was there for
her, gave her a big hug,
and said not to worry, that
he would always have her back.
Mallory, on the other hand,
understood the severity
and turned to Mark and
said, am I going to die?
Mark and I chose to be
honest but optimistic,
pragmatic but hopeful.
I adopted a mantra,
"No pity party."
The goal was to find
the joy in every day.
Mallory adopted her own mantra,
which was, "Live happy."
Now I want to tell you a
little bit about Mallory.
She was always loving,
determined, and focused.
She was tall, beautiful, and had
the longest, most perfect legs
you could ever imagine.
After she turned
13, there was really
never a time that some
boy was not after her.
She was valedictorian of her
high school, a three sport
varsity athlete, and prom queen.
She went on to Stanford and
graduated Phi Theta Kappa,
while playing club
volleyball and participating
in a lot of other
extracurricular activities.
She always had friends
because she was fun-loving,
compassionate, and kind.
After college, Mallory
returned to Los Angeles
and moved to Manhattan
Beach with friends,
where she was
surfing, socializing,
and working as a writer.
She threw herself into research
and wrote "The Gottlieb Native
Garden, a California
Love Story."
The book was covered by AP and
got tremendous press coverage.
It was the publication
of that book
that enabled Mallory to envision
life as a writer, a career that
would be both flexible
and fulfilling,
which was important because
her deep passion was
environmental education,
and everybody told her
that if she worked in the field,
it would expose her and put her
at additional risk.
But sadly, a few months
after living there,
cepacia reared its
ugly head again
and Mallory took a
turn for the worse,
ending up in the hospital
for long stretches of time.
While Mallory's
friends were grappling
with normal,
post-college questions,
Mallory had to deal with things
like IVs and indignities.
Two
Examples-- having
to use a bedside
commode to go to the bathroom
in a glass-walled ICU room
when nurses were sometimes
too busy to draw the curtain.
Sometimes they would come
in and they would ask her
about her bowel habits in front
of some new boy she had just
started dating.
It was horrifying to her.
During this period, she
was also in a lot of pain.
The opioid epidemic has thrown
traditional pain protocols
into question and has left
many patients suffering.
This was Mallory's
experience, and she
writes about being victimized.
During one
hospitalization, Mallory
told the pain
management team that she
was suffering severe pleurisy,
which is when the infection is
pressed up against the lung wall
and causes excruciating pain.
The dose they had given
her wasn't even beginning
to address it, and when she
asked her more, they refused,
saying they didn't want her
to turn into an opioid addict
and become ineligible
for transplant.
At the time, Mallory wasn't
even listed for transplant,
and because of the cepacia,
which is considered a superbug,
we weren't sure she
would ever be listed.
Mallory felt their
unresponsiveness to her pain
was equivalent to torture.
They also cited the fact
that another CF patient
down the hall had
become addicted
and was now not able
to get a transplant.
Mallory asked her CF
team to intervene.
She explained that she did
not have an addiction issue,
and she really just needed
better pain management.
They intervened,
and she was finally
able to get some relief.
The same scenario played
out again after transplant
when they had cut her chest
open, taken out her old lungs,
sewed in new lungs, and
expected her to survive
on a minimal pain dose.
It would take days and
days of horrible pain
and suffering and
screaming before they
came to understand
that they had woefully
under-treated her pain.
Now the interesting thing is
that, at a different point
in her journal, Mallory
writes about her own fears
of getting addicted.
This is a quote.
"I never thought
I would say this,
but I have come to love the
feeling of being on opioids.
It was never part
of my treatment,
but as my chest pain
became unbearable,
I needed it to breathe.
It also helped with my mood.
With morphine and with
oxy, there is no pain
and there is no sadness."
These anecdotes lead to insight
number two, fear of addiction
must be better
balanced with need when
it comes to pain management.
Mallory wanted to be part of an
industry-wide conversation that
would address both the
opioid epidemic and the very
well-documented overreaction
of well-meaning doctors
and nurses who, in their attempt
to save patients from becoming
addicts, under-treat pain.
In this era of
personalized medicine,
there is no room for one
size fits all solutions.
Advocating for better
pain management
is part of Malory's
unfinished work
and part of her unfinished life.
As Mallory's health
continued to decline,
her Stanford doctors
asked her to move back
up north so they could get
a better handle on her care.
They felt that the team at
UCLA, while stellar transplant
doctors and having
a great CF clinic,
didn't really
understand cepacia.
For a few magical months Mallory
stayed out of the hospital.
She went to yoga, hung out with
friends, and took long walks.
It was this amazing
phenomenon and it
seemed as though there had
been a dramatic quick flip
of the switch.
Now during this time,
Mallory looked so healthy
that people didn't realize what
it was she was dealing with--
67 hospitalizations
up to that point
that had ranged from weeks to
months, losing friends with CF,
her struggle to
prioritize her health
while still trying to
keep up with her friends,
the many hours
every day that she
had to do treatment,
the anxiety of burdening
the people that
she loved the most,
and her forced
contemplation of death.
It wasn't until Mallory
left for college
that she actually ever had to
think about how to tell people
about her invisible illness.
But dorm living has
a way of establishing
immediate intimacy, and
word spread quickly,
which relieved her of the
burden of having to disclose.
But after college,
the issue came up
with Jack, her real
life Prince Charming.
Mallory met Jack
on New Year's Eve.
She had just gotten out of
the hospital and was on IVs.
She thought Jack was
super cute and very nice,
but he lived in Palo
Alto and she lived in LA,
and she knew that with
her health condition
she could not manage a
long distance relationship.
So she never really gave
him a second thought.
But months later, when Malory
did move back up north,
they re-met at a party.
They were playing
a game together
when she felt a bout of
hemoptysis coming on.
Hemopytsis is when
you cough up blood,
and it can be a 911
deadly emergency.
When she came out
of the bathroom,
Jack expressed concern, which
leads to insight number three.
It's sometimes difficult
to know when to disclose
an invisible illness.
Mallory often said that
the issue of disclosure
was one of the hardest
things about having
an invisible illness.
She worried about
burdening new friends,
and worried about scaring
off potential employers.
And in one very
specific example,
Mallory applied
for a writing job,
spent two weeks
perfecting her samples,
turned them in, was told
they were fantastic,
was offered a job,
and when she told me
she was going to
start the next week,
I told her that
she needed to let
them know that she had a
disease that might render her
unable to come into the office.
When she told them, suddenly
it wasn't a good fit
and the offer was reneged.
Mallory also feared that no
man would love her enough
to accept the complications
of her disease,
so she often wrestled
with the decision
about whether or not to tell
the people that she was dating.
But with Jack, she felt that
there was something special
and she wanted him
to know right away.
She did come to the
conclusion that, in terms
of right and wrong, there
isn't really a correct answer.
But with Jack, because
she felt something,
she wanted him to know
right from the start what
he was getting into,
and she asked herself,
is this man who's
there for me when
I'm laughing and partying
going to be there for me when
I'm sick and sedated?
It was a good thing that
Mallory told Jack right away,
because very soon after, she
ended up back in the hospital,
and it the first of many
more admissions to come.
Over the next few
months, the antibiotics
seemed to stop
working and Mallory
was inching closer
to the time when
she would need a transplant.
The only center in the
country that would accept her,
because of the
cepacia, was University
of Pittsburgh
Medical Center, UPMC.
They asked us to come in
for a week-long evaluation,
and when we said,
great, anytime,
tell us when, they explained
that the difficulty would
be getting our insurance
company to say yes.
And I said, that's not
going to be a problem.
Mark went to Harvard.
He's a lawyer.
I'm a publicist.
I'll go on the Today Show
if they try to deny it.
But guess what?
They said no.
Getting insurance approval for
an out-of-state, out-of-network
hospital was the single
hardest and most excruciating
non-medical challenge
that we faced.
The battle raged on for weeks.
They employed multiple stall
tactics that Mallory felt
were intended to run the
clock out on her life.
It would absolutely take a
miracle to turn no into yes.
But in Mallory's
case, the miracle
came in the form of a very
close friend with connections
to the highest level of
insurance company's management.
Mallory knew she was
incredibly lucky,
but she understood that
not everybody would be.
She documents this journey
in "Salt in my Soul"
because she wants others to
see exactly what happened
and how she attempted
to resolve it.
Insurance companies
often inflict
needless additional suffering
on patients who are already
in pain and already at stress.
It's outrageous and
incomprehensible,
which leads to insight number
four, that doctors, not
insurance company or
insurance company doctors,
should decide who gets
care and where they get it,
and what coverage is allowed.
Mallory and I spent a
grueling week in Pittsburgh,
and the reason I say
grueling is that, in order
to be accepted for
transplant, you
have to meet with a number
of different teams--
surgeons, case managers,
financial advisors,
pharmacists.
The list goes on and on.
They want to make sure you
are physically strong enough,
emotionally strong
enough, that you
have the financial
resources to be
able to cover the expenses
that will inevitably come up,
and they want to make sure that
you have two support-givers
with you at all times.
We left Pittsburgh after that
week on pins and needles,
but hopeful, because they
seem pretty optimistic,
and on Mallory's 24th
birthday, October 12th of 2016,
the call came in saying
that UPMC was accepting her
for transplant.
But at that point, they said
she was too healthy to come,
which was quite
amazing considering
how sick she'd been.
But of course, shortly after
that, as it always happened,
she got mono and the flu
and ended up very sick,
back at UCLA Hospital-- we
brought her home to make sure
we could provide full support--
while we were waiting for them
to tell us it was time to come.
During that period, she got
so sick that at one point,
UPMC said it might
not make sense
to come if you're just
going to come here to die.
So we had to wait until
she was physically stable,
and then we could get
her across the country
for this grueling move.
Eventually, in February,
the call came on a Monday
with instructions to
be in clinic on Friday,
and to fly on Thursday.
So we had two days
to pack everything up
and say goodbye to the
people that she knew
she might not come back to.
She was most sad about
leaving her dog, Kona,
who was too big to
make the trip with us.
After a lot of upheaval, we
hunkered down in Pittsburgh
waiting for the call.
To a patient with end-stage
lung disease that's
listed for transplant, the
single most important thing
to do is wait for that call.
You can't go to the
movies, take a shower,
sleep through the night,
do anything without having
your phone tethered to you
because you cannot miss
a single call.
But what happens is, the
heightened vigilance starts
to give way to hopelessness
as days and weeks pass
and you start to think
the call will never come,
or if it comes, it
will come too late.
During that period, every single
day, I would sing to Mallory,
"Somewhere over the
rainbow, there are lungs."
Just the first
line, over and over.
But then in March, we got the
call on a Friday afternoon,
and we raced to
get to the hospital
and hunkered down
for a 24-hour wait.
During that time, she
actually made it into preop,
had a lot of tests done, and
we were cautiously optimistic
that it was going to work.
But the next
morning, they came in
to tell us that, while
the lungs were viable,
they had actually gone
to another candidate.
We didn't know that Mallory
was a backup candidate,
and at the time,
we didn't even know
that that was actually
a thing, which
leads to insight number five.
Doctors should err in favor of
giving more information rather
than less, as it helps patients
manage their expectations.
In a crazy twist of
fate, the second call
came 48 hours later.
And again we rushed
to the hospital,
waited about another 24 hours,
but again, it was a no go.
This time there was
no backup candidate,
but the lungs weren't viable.
This was the second
dry run, and there
was to be a third,
which came months later
after Mallory agreed to
accept high risk lungs.
High risk lungs are labeled that
when a person has identified
with one of three behaviors-- a
homosexual, an intravenous drug
user, or someone who has
spent time in prison.
The interesting thing about
the high risk category
is that somebody could be
any one of those things
and not disclose, so you kind
of wonder, should you accept
or should you not?
We asked the surgeon and his
answer was actually perfect.
Dr. [INAUDIBLE] said, I would
not put any lungs in you
that I didn't feel comfortable.
Your survival is as important
to me as it is to you.
The fourth call was the
one that ended up working.
On September 11 of 2017--
sort of an inauspicious
date for transplant--
Mallory finally made it into
the OR, and after nine hours,
Dr. [INAUDIBLE]
came out and told us
he was thrilled
with the outcome.
She had done quite well.
But of course
during this period,
she had vocal paralysis,
unbearable pain,
a swallowing disorder,
a list of medications
that would make your
head spin, and this
is when we experienced that
second round of the pain
management problem.
But yet, despite all of
that, to see your daughter
take her first
breath with new lungs
and no supplemental oxygen is
a sight that's indescribable.
The rehab for her was
grueling, but a month later,
on October 12th of
2017, Mallory was home
celebrating her birthday.
Well, actually her
home in Pittsburgh,
because we were still there.
During those days,
I would sing to her,
"Somewhere over the
rainbow, there were lungs,"
and you'll note the
rainbow on her cake.
It was the very
happiest time as we
dared to dream about
a new life, one
that Mallory would spend back
in California, living with Jack,
surfing, and doing
additional writing.
But a very short
few weeks later,
Mallory was readmitted
with pneumonia,
and almost immediately,
the doctors
started preparing
me for the worst.
Now I'm going to
switch and tell you
a little bit about
Mallory's journals, which
end up in "Salt in my
Soul, an Unfinished Life."
Mallory started writing
when she was 15.
She wrote anywhere she was.
She wrote at tournament's--
sports tournaments.
She wrote in the
middle of the night
when she had insomnia, on
trips, at friends' houses,
when she was doing
treatment in Hawaii.
Writing, for her, was
extremely cathartic.
Now during these years, Mallory
and I were joined at the hip.
She confided in me
about everything,
and I felt lucky to have
those years with her.
What I did to help
her also helped me.
I cooked for her,
cleaned her [INAUDIBLE],,
picked up her meds,
anything that would give
her more time with her friends.
But in the process,
it gave me a window
into what her life
was like, something
most parents of
teenagers don't get.
Her friends were so used to
me being in the background
that they treated me
like I was furniture
and I really learned a
lot about my daughter.
I wouldn't trade
that for anything.
But one day, after a very
typical mother-daughter fight,
Mallory stormed off into
her room, slammed the door,
and started pounding
on her laptop.
From then on, I assumed her
journal was a repository
for all of her anger at me.
I imagined her detailing
every single thing I had ever
done wrong as a mother, and
it was a terrifying thought.
I didn't actually read her
journal until she passed away.
She had kept it
password protected,
and despite my repeated
attempts to break into it,
was never able to find it.
But the day of her memorial, I
opened it for the first time,
hoping to find
something that I could
use when speaking about her.
What I found was 2,500 pages,
organized chronologically,
with each entry date stamped,
in electronic journals,
with zero expression
of anger at me.
It was the most precious
and unexpected gift
a grieving mother
could expect, and I
believe that she left
it that way because she
knew that I would read it.
Mallory was incredibly
articulate and astute,
and in her journal she
describes so many things
that are helpful both to
the medical community,
to other patients, to
health care providers,
and to those who love
people with chronic illness.
She highlights big picture
issues that are important,
but she also talks about
how the daily decisions
that each caretaker makes
can impact the day to day
quality of life for a patient.
That includes doctors, nurses,
respiratory therapists, OT,
case managers, janitors--
the list goes on and on.
Which leads to my
final insight that I
will share of hers today.
A life-threatening
illness puts you
at the intersection of so
many public health issues,
and turns you into
an accidental expert
about what can and should
be improved in patient care.
I still struggle every day to
accept that Mallory is gone.
When she first passed
away, I spent months
reading and rereading
her journals,
laughing and crying
at every page.
The big surprise was that her
journals revealed a darker
truth about her
experiences and emotions
that she had not wanted
to share during her life.
Her facade of perfection
was just that.
Malory did live happy.
But in her writing
she does express anger
at her disease, shame about
her body and its failings,
the difficulty of straddling
the sick and the well world,
her fear of dying.
But along with that,
the importance to her
of friendship, her
deep desire for love,
and most heartbreaking
to me, the fact that she
wanted a child.
It's impossible to capture
Mallory's life in one talk
or share all of the
insights that she offers.
She was awe-inspiring,
and her memory
will be forever etched in
the hearts and minds of those
who loved her, but will now be
also in the hearts and minds
of those who read her work.
Losing Mallory was catastrophic.
There's no other
way to describe it.
But what we've
come to understand
is that sometimes, a
heartbreaking ending can
be the beginning of a triumph.
Mallory's legacy is in her
wit, her words, and her wisdom,
the salt in her soul.
Thank you.
So I think now we're going to
invite Jack, the boyfriend, who
actually writes in the book, and
Mark, the dad and husband, who
also contributes in
the book, to come up.
And if anybody
has any questions,
we'd be happy to answer them.
AUDIENCE: Mallory comes from a
family with a lot of resources
and the ability to do some
pretty incredible things--
moving around the country,
all the time you were
able to dedicate, et cetera.
How applicable is
this experience
to other kinds of
families who don't
have those kinds of resources?
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
Well, it's interesting.
One of the palliative
care social workers
at Children's Hospital,
whose name is Danielle Jonas,
told me very early on.
She had come to the hospital
and spent time with Mallory
and she knew about the writing.
And she said to
me, you absolutely
must make the story
public because I
work with under-served families
at Children's Hospital in LA,
and when their child
dies, they actually
think that their child
died because they
couldn't provide better
care or better resources.
And the message here is
that you can have money.
You can have access.
You can have privilege.
You can still suffer and
your child can still die.
Mallory suffered.
Having access to health care
and the transplant, of course,
extended her life a little bit.
But at the end of the day,
it didn't change the outcome.
And so hopefully people
will learn from the message,
don't feel guilty.
Don't feel bad.
Do what you can.
But disease runs its
own course sometimes
and there's nothing you can do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for your courage
to share this
story, and I'm just
amazed how you, as
a mother, held it
all together in sharing this.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: I have
to fight crying each time.
AUDIENCE: Oh my gosh.
You're amazingly articulate
and your words were beautiful.
I wanted to find
out how you've been
able to translate all of
this incredible knowledge
and perspective to
the medical community.
I can imagine you feel
it's your life's desire
to see change in the system
to better help people
of the future who
will have to be
under these horrible
circumstances.
What's happening in
that path for you,
and have you found any
headway or response
to this amazing work and
the work that you're doing?
DIANE SHADER SMITH: So it hasn't
even been three weeks, I think,
that the book came
out on March 12.
So I'm sort of at the
beginning of the journey.
I am doing 70 talks, and
more offers are coming in.
And so far, I've spoken to
one medical school and a group
of residents-- a resident's
council on the medical school
at University of Pennsylvania.
And what I'm hearing
is that the message
is very important
for them because they
will learn from an
actual case study,
in addition to what they're
studying in the textbook.
But I've had offers
from some other
of the medical
professionals that I'm
speaking at their institutions
to do some more extensive work,
and it was suggested,
for example,
that I work on curriculum.
And I will do that, because
now that Mallory is not
here, all of the energy
and passion and commitment
that I had to
taking care of her,
I want to translate that
into taking her messages on.
People who've read the
book write to me every day.
It's unbelievable that
it's helping empower them.
It's helping them understand.
And fortunately, the
press has been amazing,
so I don't have to
be as braggy as I
might have to be otherwise.
But it is important, first,
to get the word out there,
and then to take it
to the next level,
to try to figure out
which particular area I
think I'll spend most time on.
I know for me, I think that the
surprising thing is that, when
I first worked on the
journal and thought
I was going to bring
it to publication,
that it was going
to be most relevant
and important for the CF
community and the transplant
community.
But what I've sort of
come to understand is,
people like it in that community
because it sort of gives them
that feeling of familiarity
and shared experience.
But there are a lot
of other communities
that I hadn't thought would
be benefited by, for example,
the mental illness community.
I've done a talk for
the National Alliance
on Mental Illness
in Los Angeles,
and they explained that all
of the issues about fear,
depression, and anxiety
that Mallory writes about,
and the issue of disclosure
and invisible illness
are so important.
And so I recognize I'm
at sort of the beginning
of this journey,
and I would love
you to ask me the
question in the year, when
I finish most of
the talks, and then
I will be sure to report back.
But I will definitely
do something.
I can't imagine
anything more important.
AUDIENCE: What are
some of the things that
are happening today to help
with this type of outcome?
What are some of the things that
you're looking at research-wise
to help patients such as this?
MARK SMITH: Well, some
friends of Mallory
who collaborated with her
to organize a charity called
Lunges with Lungs--
and there's a link to
that on the website--
it raises money for
rejection research, which
is a big problem, obviously,
in transplant cases, not just
lung transplants but
across the board.
And then we're also
working to promote
an experimental treatment
that Mallory got.
This story is in the book and
in the postscript, especially.
It's called phage therapy and
it was kind of a Hail Mary pass
that we made at the
end of Mallory's life
to see if we could eradicate
the B. cepacia infection
and save her life.
We did end up getting
phage therapy for Mallory,
but it was about
a week too late.
And she had a few doses.
The autopsy indicated that
the medicine was working,
but it was too late
to save her life.
Since she died, interest
in phage therapy
has been reignited, and
a cystic fibrosis patient
in San Diego with a
nasty pulmonary infection
was rejected for
transplant, and then
treated with phage
therapy, and then put back
on the transplant list.
And there's other cases
at Yale and in the UK
and one more in Pittsburgh
where they have successfully
used the therapy that we
tried to get for Mallory
and cleared an infection in
a cystic fibrosis patient,
and we're hopeful that that
will become a standard part
of the treatment.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
And we should
mention that we're donating
all profits from the book.
We don't want to make
any money from the book.
Both Mark and I are full
time working professionals
and we don't need the
money, and so we're
using this tour to raise
money and awareness
for phage therapy
because by the year 2050,
10 million people per year
will die from superbugs,
and phage therapy will be
relevant and applicable,
not just for patients with CF
or those immunocompromised,
but everybody who gets
a superbug infection.
And if you don't know
about phage therapy,
you can read about
the journey that we
had with it in the book.
You can also Google it online.
It's [INAUDIBLE] use the Google.
You can Google it and you'll
find a lot of information
about it.
It's very important.
That was not an intended
plug, by the way.
I just--
MARK SMITH: There's also a
link on the web page, which
is SaltInMySoulBook.com, a
link to donate to phage therapy
or to the rejection research.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
She has a question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, me.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Microphone.
AUDIENCE: So this question
is a life question.
We each know that we don't
know tomorrow is guaranteed
for any one of us or
anyone in our family,
but it seems like there's
always that special gift
of knowing that you have
only a certain amount of time
with someone.
And I would like to
know, for each of you,
how you dealt with today,
knowing that tomorrow
was going to come.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
Who wants to start?
MARK SMITH: Jack.
JACK: Right.
So Mallory, because of her
illness, her sense of mortality
was at the forefront of her
decisions from a young age
and it affected a lot of
her decisions she made.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
Talk slower and louder.
JACK: Sure.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Sorry.
JACK: So she loved her friends.
She loved the environment.
She loved the ocean,
which had a lot of salt
and it helped her breathe more.
She knew that she
would plant seeds
that would grow into trees that
would create shade that she
would never be able to sit in.
So that was very clear for her.
Your question is how
did it affect us.
I thought that some of the
more challenging moments--
seeing her through
transplant, seeing
her go to the brink of
death and come back,
holding her in our hands when
she passed away together--
I thought those would
be the harder moments.
But the harder moments
have actually been now.
How do you honor a legacy
that is so extraordinary?
That's the question I
ask myself routinely
and it's one that we all
have different answers to,
but it's one we're
still figuring out.
She wanted a future that her
desired child, the kid she
hoped for, would be
able to be happy in,
so she was very cognizant of
the world that she left behind.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
I would answer that,
and I would say very simply,
Mallory chose to live happy,
and Mark and I, from the
time she was very young,
made the decision that we were
not going to live a pity party,
and that, however short her time
was, it would be a lot of fun.
And we had a magnificent and
amazing 25 years with her.
I would not trade
it for anything.
And I do believe that
Mallory accomplished
and did as much in 25 years as
many people do in a lifetime.
It just was condensed.
And now the loss for
us is catastrophic,
but when you read the
material that she left,
you won't believe it.
It's just staggering how
she's able to articulate.
She dealt with the highest
highs and the lowest lows,
and her resilience, her
strength, her determination,
her desire to live--
she left instructions
before transplant.
She wanted ECMO, she
wanted ventilator,
she wanted any heroics
necessary to stay alive.
She wanted to
live, and it's hard
not to be happy when you're with
somebody who, despite the worst
and most overwhelming
obstacles, gets up
every day with a smile on
her face and pushes forward.
That sets the tone.
JACK: I have a phrase
that encapsulates that.
Mallory had a knack
that she was very
good at of turning some
of her darkest moments
into some of her finest hours.
She was a champion all the
time and had so much resolve
that I'm still inspired by.
MARK SMITH: Mallory lived
happy, but Diane and I also
strove to be happy.
My feeling was, if
we allowed ourselves
to become despondent
because of her illness,
then the message she would get
is, she had ruined our lives.
And the truth is she
did not ruin our lives.
She enriched them greatly.
And we always tried to
find the joy in every day
and to squeeze every
last drop of life out.
And I'm confident that we did.
I would not say that
Mallory had an unhappy life.
I think that, overall, she
had a blessed and happy life.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys
all for coming so much.
I really appreciate it.
Diane, I just wanted to
compliment you and comment
on your vigorous attitude with
this whole entire process.
We know it's not an easy
thing to go through.
I was raised by a single mother
myself and she was definitely
momma bear my whole
life, still is, in fact.
So to you two, I
wanted to know, how
can we, as men and
boyfriends, support
throughout this journey?
How can we offer our support?
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
Make your joke.
Tell your joke.
MARK SMITH: What's my joke?
DIANE SHADER SMITH: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK SMITH: Oh yeah.
When Diane started setting up
all the talks on her book tour
and she started
working on her speech,
and I helped her with
the speech and it
went through multiple drafts.
She asked if I wanted to speak
too, and at a couple of events
I've spoken about phage
therapy, but the audience
that she has for the book talks
isn't really the right audience
for the phage therapy talk.
But Diane did say that she
wanted me to come and travel
with her and attend as many
of the speeches as I could.
And so I told her
that I was going
to get myself one of
those little red vests
that says "Emotional
support animal."
DIANE SHADER SMITH: I
keep waiting for him
to show up in it one day.
MARK SMITH: Yeah, I haven't
figured out how to do it yet.
The dog kind don't
really fit a human body,
so I may have to
commission it to be made.
But in response to your
question, how can you help,
one of the things that
is really poignant when
you read Mallory's book,
especially if you knew her
and then you read the book,
is how much suffering she
went through.
And she chose not to
share a lot of it with me.
I think she shared
more with her mother.
Some of her friends say
they actually felt guilty
when they read the book for not
knowing how much suffering she
went through.
But she concealed that from
us because she loved us.
And I think it's important
for everybody, men and women,
to understand that you see
only a very tiny little bit
of what's going on in
another person's life,
and there's often
a whole iceberg
there below the surface.
So keep that in mind, I think,
when you deal with people,
whether they're sick or not.
Sometimes you don't
know that they're sick.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: I want
to answer that question too.
So I would say two words--
show up.
And I can give an example
and an anecdote with Jack.
So there was really catastrophic
news in the summer of August--
I think it was August of 2016--
when Stanford came in
and said, the antibiotics
aren't working anymore
and we're out of options
and I don't know that any
center is going to accept you.
And so we said--
I said-- no pity party.
No negativity.
Nothing in the room that's bad.
And Jack, who had been
ever-present, always there, day
in and day out, just
disappeared for three days,
and Mallory was devastated.
And then he finally
came and explained--
and you can ask him if
you want what happened--
but what he
explained to me was--
or he explained to
Mallory and Mallory
told me-- was that he heard
me with my no negativity
and he was too sad and
crying and couldn't be there.
And Mallory said very clearly,
I don't care if you cry.
I don't care if you're sad.
But I want you in
the room with me.
And I think that the most
important thing-- it's sort of
like with Mark.
If he doesn't speak, if
he doesn't do anything
more than just show up,
it's an amazing support
to know that somebody
is there, to have
a rock when you're alone and
struggling with whatever it is.
MARK SMITH: I
don't just show up.
I also lead the applause.
AUDIENCE: So Jack, I'll
shift it over to you.
JACK: Sure.
Yeah, obviously--
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Do
you remember that episode?
Remember that?
JACK: Of course, yeah.
There's this perception
now that I'd always
been a good partner,
a good boyfriend.
But it obviously
wasn't always the case.
Mallory was a great
teacher as well as partner,
so I learned a lot from dating
her that I hope to share now.
One of the struggles
that I face now
is, there is no word for
what position I hold now.
I'm not a widow.
Mallory and I talked about
marriage and children,
but decided to put off
engagement and things like that
so that she could
fight for her life.
That's a pretty important goal.
But now I think of
myself as a quasi-widow,
the former boyfriend to
this incredible woman.
And so to answer
your question, how
do we as men, or former
boyfriends in my case,
honor her legacy and show
that in their restraint?
And it's one I'm
still working on.
One of the most
rewarding parts of this
has been the inspiration people
have shared with me of Mallory
and I as a couple.
It's not like she became sick
after I started dating her.
I knew all of that
upfront, going into it.
But she was such an
extraordinary woman
that it was so clear to
stay with her for me.
I have no regrets of dating her.
She was incredible.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
AUDIENCE: So Tim and I have
a 22-year-old son with CF.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Oh, you do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So thank you, all three of you,
for sharing your experiences.
And I could ask you
a lot of questions,
but I really wanted to focus on
your two issues of disclosure
because there were
two perspectives.
One was, would you
still advise a patient
with CF or other chronic
illness, to disclose that to--
DIANE SHADER SMITH: 100%,
and I can explain why,
or if you want to ask
your second question.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
is, the lack of disclosure on
the part of the medical team,
with respect to, you were the
second in line for the lung
transplant, things like that.
Are there ways that we can help
them to be more open with us?
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Well OK,
I'll answer the second question
first.
By speaking out, we're
raising awareness.
And I have already
given 15 talks
and I've already done a
lot of press interviews
and I've already heard
back from a lot of people.
And so it sparks conversation
and it triggers conversation,
which, back to your question,
what I'm going to do,
I'm going to poke
the bear is what
I'm going to do in the process.
I don't know what
I'm going to land on,
but for right now I'm
going to raise the issue.
And it's funny, because a lot
of the medical institutions
wanted to see the
talk, and I was
like, I'm not sending my talk.
You don't have to take me.
But it took me a
long time to land
on what I felt was most
important to share.
But I think if you just
express to your caretakers--
your CF team, I'm not sure
where you're treated--
that you want full information.
And part of Mallory's--
and I mentioned this
early in the talk.
Part of why she
got such good care
is because she was able to
articulate exactly what she
was feeling and thinking.
She understood her symptoms.
She knew what her
treatments were.
She understood what was
happening in her body.
And I think that her
being so open and honest
and communicative helped
them be that way with her.
But back to your question
about whether disclosure
is important.
I overwhelmingly
feel that when you
tell people what
is going on, 90%
of the people, 99% of the
people, whatever the number is,
are supportive and
caring and kind.
If an employer
withdraws an offer,
it's good that your son
is not starting that job,
because you don't
want your son to work
in a place that doesn't
want somebody to have
that as a chronic illness.
And I didn't want
Mallory to take that job.
She was really sick at the time.
She had a great
freelance writing career.
She had plenty of opportunities.
What she was longing for
was that office feeling.
She was so jealous
of all of her friends
who got to go to Uber
or Lyft or Google
or Facebook or Airbnb
and all the places.
They were all working in
these cool startups and fun
companies, and she
was at home and felt
very lonely and very isolated.
I said to her, you are going
to compromise your health
by doing it.
And as it turned
out, she was already
compromised to the point where,
a week after that incident
happened, she ended up
back in the hospital.
And it was very clear to me
she shouldn't take the job.
But that said, I
raised the anecdote
because I think it's important
for people to remember,
and I think that--
my advice to you
as a mom to mom is
to help your son
figure out a career
that he can do with his
limitations that will embrace
and accept him for who he is.
And now, with the friggin'
portable vests, I mean--
Mallory would be a lot
healthier, I think,
if she had been able to take
that vest everywhere with her
and not have had to skip
some of the treatments
for whatever reasons that
she chose to skip them,
and she was pretty compliant.
MARK SMITH: On that
issue of the medical team
disclosing more to
you, I think just
by talking about the issue, we
encourage medical professionals
to consider the disclosure
issue from the standpoint
of the patient and the family.
And I think they
mostly consider it
from the standpoint
of HIPAA regulations.
DIANE SHADER SMITH:
And I have to tell you,
there are so many more
issues that have come up.
I'll give you a three
sentence example.
They kick parents out of the
ICU at shift change because
of HIPAA, and they
want to make sure
that, when they're doing
their bedside reporting,
that patient confidentiality
is not being--
so Mallory had her transplant.
She had made us
promise and swear,
up and down in every
direction, that we would never
ever leave her alone.
And Mark and Jack and I
rotated, because he flew in
and Mark was there
at that point.
And I was at home sleeping,
and Jack was at home
sleeping in the apartment,
and Mark was on duty,
and the nurses refused
to do the report bedside.
And Mallory was
ventilated at that point,
and sedated and drugged out,
and they refused to do report.
They wanted to kick him out.
It became a big brouhaha.
And Mallory scribbled on
a thing, Dad, it's OK.
You can leave.
I want them to do the
reporting bedside.
I want to hear it and then
they'll get you and come back.
I was home asleep and
about, apparently,
15 minutes after this incident
happened, the phone rings.
I will never forget this moment.
And I'm in my half
exhausted sleep
and I say, oh, it's Mallory.
Why is Mallory calling me?
Uh-oh.
What's wrong?
And I answer the phone
and I hear this--
[BANGING ON LECTERN]----
at the top of my lungs.
And I knew instantly there
was a problem and I knew--
I don't know how I knew--
she was hitting the phone.
It was just so obvious to me.
I screamed for Jack.
I handed him the phone.
I say, talk to her.
Don't stop talking.
Keep talking.
Let her hear your voice.
Soothe her.
Comfort her.
I call Mark, screaming like
a crazy, raging lunatic.
He goes back in and
we go racing over,
and the bottom line
is, this is the policy.
If you Google ICU shift
change, you will see,
it comes up in big
letters that it's
customary protocol to ask
the families and loved
ones to leave.
Now the stupidest thing of all.
When is the time that the
patient is paying the least
attention to you?
I mean the nurse.
The nurse is paying the
least attention to you
supposedly when they're
engaged in passing the notes
from the night to the day.
And so what that
means is at the time
they're actually
talking to each other,
how could they be paying
attention to their patient?
So this is one issue
that is not in my speech,
but it's something that I
feel really strongly about
and it's something I
want to work hard for.
But if I were you and I had
a kid that ever ended up
in the hospital,
I would make sure
that you dealt with
that issue right away.
HIPAA waiver.
Obvious duh.
You've signed the HIPAA waiver.
You're allowed to speak
in front of your son.
But we had one,
Mallory had signed it,
and still they kicked Mark out.
KEVIN: Great.
Thank you, Diane, Jack,
and Mark for this talk,
and thank you all for coming.
MARK SMITH: Thanks.
DIANE SHADER SMITH: Thank you.